géraldine dupont 1 pourquoi du coup non
mais vous vous diriez vous appelez
dupont durand
non j'aime bien chaffin ça me va très
bien car les américains
non c'est la première fois que je vais
en fait
quand j'étais petit je venais ici en
vacances avec la famille quel est votre
personnage exactement dans
je joue la femme de jivago d'abord sa
fiancée ensuite sa femme celle qu'il
délaisse pour l'autre
c'est un personnage à multiples facettes
c'est un personnage très intéressant et
un personnage que j'aime beaucoup ça
c'est une femme
pour la femme idéale gentil
si m
féminines c'est un personnage qui vous
ressemble
pourquoi vous êtes le contraire de ça
un peu oui justement parce que vous me
disiez que cette ce personnage celle
d'une femme douce et compréhensive
je m'aime pas vous dire je vais me faire
de la mauvaise publicité
ce contenu
douze mois géraldine est ce que votre
nom est dur à porter non au contraire en
avant
c'est facile de dire où chante la
sporthèque ça c'est pas vrai c'est un
avantage chez nord est aujourd'hui votre
avis oui mais ce qu'aujourd'hui votre
père est satisfait content d'eux
passée cette carrière oui il a vu six
wagons et m'a trouvé très doux c'est
pour ça que vous engagez dans pour la
comtesse de hong kong
vous jouez vous en mettra de cette façon
parce que toujours dans ses films depuis
qu'il a fait lite on fait tous toute sa
famille ont fait des petits bouts comme
ça il est dur avec vous pour vous
diriger mais non mais idiot j'ai même
passé la figuration
il ya toute la famille chaplin dans ce
film je crois où il s'appelait tout
petit si tout est possible